aoc is slamming people in her own party
like james carville who says wokeness
cost them big after getting trounced
last week in the elections
but what's wrong with just stupid
wokeness some of these people need to go
to a woke detox center or something i
mean that they're expressing the
language that people just don't use
and there's a backlash and a frustration
at that time it's too big he isn't a
sweatshirt jesse progressive darling aoc
says woke is a word used mostly by older
people and it is dangerous to think that
her party has a problem she also added
on twitter quote woke is a term pundits
are now using as a derogatory euphemism
for civil rights and justice greg woke
is their word i know
it's not fair they get to use derogatory
euphemisms about us right we did not
all we did
is we pointed a spotlight at it they're
basically saying why did you cover us we
were we appreciated being woke under the
cloak of darkness how dare you report on
us how dare you pay attention nobody has
to exaggerate any of this stuff the
headlines are like when you get a woke
headline where they say they're banning
a word or a costume you always think
that it's like some kind of red meat uh
click bait and then you read it you go
no it's for real but when you look at
this stuff aoc should listen this really
isn't a war it's an intervention you
have decent people in the in the
democratic party who are trying to
reason with the woke contingent
out of this very addictive filter of
race and oppression politics it's really
addictive because you can use it almost
anywhere and it masquerades as some kind
of thoughtful scholarship but the
problem with trying to wake up the woke
is you can't because the woke believes
by definition you're unconscious you're
guilty of unconscious racism i'm awake
how dare you say i'm not awake so you
can't really wake the woke
i can't wake the woke uh harold's she's
essentially making the argument too that
if you're using the term woke
as a derogatory term that you are not
interested in racial justice so she's
alleging that james carville for example
isn't interested in those issues and
wants him to kind of go away and stop
giving advice to the party would you
agree with that well i don't know she i
know she said some pundits so i guess
she one could say she was talking about
james carpenter james carville is a
person i know and is for a long time
been committed to civil rights and and
and racial justice that being said
woke was on the ballot uh a week ago
whether we like it or not whether we
want to call it that or not and it
didn't win
um that doesn't mean the principles and
some of the positives behind it are not
valid and valuable and should not be you
know elevated but the way it's been
talked about now is not serving any of
that agenda and frankly it's not serving
the party that uh the congresswoman is a
member of at some point you have to
understand politics is about making
progress not progress
by you don't measure progress in
politics by advancing your own agenda
or your own set of priorities but actual
priorities for the people whom you
represent and you don't have to
understand that there are other people
you're serving with so you can't always
get everything you want uh it's called
life as well and politics is a microcosm
of that i hope that this uh that james
carville and others who are committed
democrats and
dedicated their lives to advancing
causes that want to make the country
better and fairer uh that we all sit
back and listen and i would hope that
those who are perceived to be the woke
members of my party that they take a
step back and understand what's being
said here so dana woke seems to be
something that was trendy and is now out
of fashion because you don't like it as
much as they did maybe last summer at
the height of blm when corporations were
dumping billions of dollars into the
woke movement they were fine with
everybody using the term then but now
all of a sudden they don't want it it's
like aoc turned the hose on ourselves
right because it was like they were
spraying everybody else and getting
everybody um all uh criticizing
everybody because they weren't woke
enough and then all of a sudden they're
like well wait how could how dare you
use our words against us well that's
actually called politics and it's called
persuasion and that's how it works um
the woke problem is very potent because
it's a larger issue for the democrats
because while the president is focused
on for example tree equity
and all these climate change programs
people are like but my gas prices are
way up and you're talking about
cancelling a pipeline for and it doesn't
there's just a complete disconnect the
other thing is i think there's a big
problem that and this is true of all of
us we could all be better listeners okay
but she and and people who are mad at
carville or maureen dowd of the new york
times she wrote the same thing
and
they're so concerned with the who is
saying it rather than the what is being
said that they can't even hear so it's
like well that person's old that
person's white that person doesn't have
our best interest in mind now that's not
true you think maureen dowd doesn't want
president biden to succeed of course he
does or she might even want she might
have even won in bernie sanders i don't
remember who she supported but basically
you have
a this disconnect that is causing them
so many problems that now you have the
possibility have anybody seen the
articles about rural america this
weekend
we shared them over coffee the democrats
are being shut out across the board in
the count city and local elections the
county elections the state houses that
means there's no one there to actually
do any sort of
democratic
outreach in those states and they are
looking at a possible complete and total
shutout and then there you wait till you
hear the hows about the electoral
college because of that well jesse
though do you know why uh joe biden
didn't like the pipeline oh no gives you
gas
yeah he doesn't like that very much
especially if he's uh in front of the
royal family overseas not embarrassing
us uh jessie would you like to follow up
on that uh just not that but in general
i will and your choice of topic but the
democrats are very divided and katie i
am delighted by it you have the i guess
the bill clinton wing of the parties
james carville they won two national
elections they won in the burbs in the
south in the cities and they focused on
kitchen table issues got burned a little
bit by the culture wars then moved back
to the center had a pretty popular
pro-business presidency at the end so he
comes out and he says well for example
they're taking abraham lincoln's name
off schools and they're defunding the
police and where does he source this
wokeness from the faculty lounge now he
knows you can't have the intelligentsia
running a national political party these
are the people that gave us communism
critical race theory restorative justice
political correctness that's crazy so
you can't go woke on a national level
you can only take it so far in the
cities new york and seattle and buffalo
even they pump the brakes on this stuff
and carvel said a lot of democrats are
afraid to speak out against this because
they're going to get slandered as bigots
by the socialist wing and that's the
point the socialist wing uses wokeness
to
smear anybody that disagrees with
socialist policies so if you're joe
manchin and you oppose trillions in
welfare and amnesty and all this garbage
then what did they squad say about him
he's he's
anti-black he's anti-woman he's
anti-immigrant and god forbid you're for
free speech or
private property you're downright white
supremacists at that point so the
playbook is simple you label something
racist just to get rid of it and the
american people are not going to put up
with that anymore that's destroyed a lot
of their coalitions which is not good
for them hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now